I feel like people do things wrong and
as a society we kind of overreact yeah
like I feel like there's this strange
moment where people just decide that
we're all gonna hate some celebrity for
no real reason at all right you had a
collection there of people like for
example how did Nickelback
Nickelback takes a lot of heat and so
you put them in that scene and I thought
it was very cool of them to do it yeah I
mean they were I don't know anything
about Nickelback but I know that like my
friends that are super cool despised
Nickelback
right fake kidnap the Lindbergh baby
yeah it's like they're just just they're
playing music if you don't like it turn
it off
yeah you know and I just in most of my
friends that complain I'm like you
you're complaining but like you wait
tables you know they sell out arenas but
I just and so we wanted to capture that
because some people are in the outrage
jail for something they did wrong and
sometimes like like carrot top I mean
carrot top really didn't do anything
wrong but people are angry at him yeah
people are I guess I get mad at
character I don't know why I don't know
why props I don't know it's just prop
comedy it is funny you bring up the
Nickelback thing because it is a source
of people act like they're murderers yes
and again I don't I I don't happen to
listen to their music but they don't
make me angry and they're perfectly nice
guys it's not like you meet them and
they're monsters they're they're not
somebody that would be very rude but I
don't you know I think it's just people
define themselves by criticizing other
things and I think that's wrong Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you